Thanks Greg for the introduction. One's ability to find meaning in a stressful
event or situation can be an important predictor of one's overall physiological
as well as psychological health. Sometimes in life we're exposed to devastating
situations. Such as a loss of a loved one, a natural disaster, like a tornado
or an earthquake. Or even a life threatening or debilitating disease. How does
one handle that or cope? What type of attitude would you have if you found out
you had late stage cancer? It turns out that how we look at the situation can
be important for our health. That is, if you're able to step back and look at
the big picture and find meaning in the situation, you actually may have a
better overall health outcome than those who can't do that.